[Musique]
bonsoir le journal de tv soixante dix
huit pour faire le tour de l'actualité
locale bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez
voici les titres de ce mardi 17 décembre
nouvelle journée de mobilisation contre
la réforme des retraites l'ensemble des
principales organisations syndicales
appelaient à défiler contre le projet du
gouvernement des manifestations dans
toute la france notamment à versailles
où environ 600 personnes ont marché dans
la rue une liste citoyenne déclaré à
villepreux en vue des élections
municipales 2020 valérie ben conduira
cette candidature qui rassemble
essentiellement des habitants
une réunion d'information se tenait
samedi dernier
et puis découverte dans cette édition de
l'est qui coaching à auffargis deux
hommes dispense cette méthode avec un
cheval auprès des entreprises objectif
renforcer la cohésion et développer la
confiance en soi
on parlera dans cette édition dans cette
édition des musiques du monde avec le
festival x1 qui se tient en fin de
semaine à saint rémy les chevreuse
13e jour de grève contre la réforme des
retraites à l'appel des principaux
syndicats 350 mille personnes ont défilé
par dans les rues de paris d'après la
cgt
dans un instant on aura par téléphone
une enseignante des yvelines qui était
dans la manifestation mobilisation
également en début d'après midi dans les
rues de versailles le cortège est passé
par le château l'hôtel de ville elle a
gardé chantier et les bureaux du medef
78 sur place michael et demi d'euros
accompagné et de patrick jacques de
dixmude aux moyens techniques plusieurs
mobilisation était organisée aujourd'hui
dans les yvelines contre la réforme des
retraites
amante à poissy ou encore au vésinet
mais le plus grand rassemblement était
ici à versailles plus de 350 personnes
se sont réunies devant la préfecture
pour défiler je suis avec yves de la
cfdt de thales elancourt alors il
pourquoi vous manifester aujourd'hui
manifestent aujourd'hui donc pour la
réforme des retraites
et puis on est présent ici de façon
unitaire ou parce que nous semble que
ces importantes et un moment
on passe le message qui est porté par
les syndicats soient claires et simples
pour les salariés en fait alors la cfdt
et on peut le dire minoritaires ici sur
cette manifestation il ya beaucoup de
cgt est-ce que vous avez est ce que
ponce est important que la sécurité soit
représentée dans ce cortège
l'enjeu est supérieur à pas déjà des as
des choses des concurrences
intersyndicale qui n'ont aucun intérêt
en parallèle de la réforme des retraites
les syndicats ont également profité pour
défendre certains métiers
alors il ya quelques postiers qui sont
ici sur cette manifestation à versailles
pourquoi les postiers se mobilisent
alors les postiers de versailles se
mobilisent aujourd'hui pour leurs
conditions de travail
ils ont une réorganisation interne qui
se passent mal avec des très très grosse
tournée avec plein de petits problèmes
et qui a cumulé fait que bah c'est plus
possible pour distribuer le courrier en
bonne dans de bonnes conditions
aujourd'hui
donc ils sont en grève pour montrer
alors et pour renouer le dialogue avec
leur direction pour que les choses
s'arrangent pour qu'ils puissent
travailler dans de bonnes conditions
pour rendre le service aux usagers
parce que aujourd'hui à des problèmes de
distribution de courrier dans versailles
au départ du cortège les manifestants
étaient finalement plus de 600 à défiler
dans les rues versaillaise
monde ça ne sont pas absolument pas
c'est une volonté je pense d'essayer de
venir dans les dents les dans les
chalets dire dans les orties râpeux de
paris pour les manifestations et ça
m'étonne coque et beaucoup de monde ce
qu'est le moment non qui sont concernés
qui n'ont pas forcément réussir à et
dans paris devant l'épreuve de transport
est évidemment non c'est plutôt bien ça
ne m'étonne pas qu'ils ont tout le monde
que ça ce matin que la secrétaire
général de la cgt dans les yvelines
sonia porot soutien pour est ce que vous
êtes en skis et autant ici à verser bas
on savait que la colère était très très
porteur déjà deux pilotes le 5 décembre
mais à voir autant de monde
aversenq ce exceptionnel ça fait
plusieurs années que ce n'était pas
arrivé
il parcourt l'europe apce on est parti
de la préfecture ont fait devant le
château de versailles qui est fermée
puisque à nombreux grévistes ont pas
passé devant l' agence régionale de
santé puisqu'elle les personnels
hospitaliers sont mobilisés depuis des
mois pour des moyens et pouvoir faire
correctement leur travail
le cortège a terminé son chemin au siège
du medef
ici à versailles à l'heure actuelle
aucune autre manifestation n'est
programmé ici dans la commune des
actions locales également à la
queue-lez-yvelines au plus de soixante
enseignants se sont réunis contre la
réforme des retraites avant de se rendre
dans le cortège parisien
marion chaumette avec nous par téléphone
bonsoir oui bonsoir vous êtes enseignant
de philosophie dans les yvelines
grévistes mais non syndiqués vous étiez
ce matin au rassemblement à la
queue-lez-yvelines et cet après-midi
dans le cortège parisien a déjà un petit
bilan sur la mobilisation annoncée dans
les yvelines 20% de grévistes chez les
enseignants du premier degré plus de la
moitié dans le secondaire est ce que la
grève a été très suivie dans les
yvelines
il me faut qu'elle ait quelques alors je
me permets juste des corrigés société
part au rassemblement à la
queue-lez-yvelines puisque je vis sur
paris donc j'ai retrouvé mes collègues
avec leurs pancartes et leurs banderoles
dans la manifestation parisienne
mais oui j'ai suivi près cette
mobilisation fin nous sommes là c'est
important dans les divines et surtout ce
qui me semble assez nouveau c'est que ça
rassemble des collègues qui sont de
différents établissements et aussi de
différents degrés 1 2 de l'école
maternelle en fait jusqu'au dit fier et
moi une forme que c'est ça surtout qui
est important c'est que là il ya
vraiment un ton assez unie contre des
réformes qui nous semble injuste pour
nous et injuste pour tous les français
en fait voilà en ce qui concerne
justement cette réforme des retraites
qui provoquent la colère des professeurs
l'une des colères en tout cas des
professeurs c'est le calcul des pensions
de retraite des retraites aujourd'hui ce
sont les six derniers mois de travail
effectués avant la retraite qui sont
prises en compte dans le calcul de cette
tension avec la réforme le calcul se
ferait sur l'ensemble de la carrière
avec forcément une baisse de cette
pension est ce que vous estiment être
les grands perdants de cette réforme
bah je suis passé les grands perdants
parce que j'aimerais dire qu'il ya un
peu un coucours des perdants moi ce qui
me semble important c'est qu'en fait
tout le monde est perdant 4 et femmes
vraiment tout le monde
alors certains c'est sûr plus que
d'autres à les femmes sont plus perdante
que les hommes les personnes qui ont des
carrières un petit peu à chier ou qui
ont des emplois précaires sont plus
perdants ce qui est certain c'est que
les enseignants sont extrêmement touchés
par cette réforme c'est des pertes de
pensions qu on peut estimer à entre 300
et 900 euros par mois c'est en effet
assez massif et je crois que sur tout ce
que ça dit c'est ce qu'on voit là dedans
outre une perte
nos conditions par bas de nos conditions
de vie dans un certain âge c'est le
mépris en fait avec lequel on est
traités mais ça c'est pas tout à fait
nouveau et voilà la coupe est un peu
plein sans doute en son nom le
gouvernement a annoncé quelques mesures
de compensation sanctuary zélés les
pensions des enseignants en augmentant
leur salaire en favorisant six
versements de primes
edouard philippe le premier ministre a
d'ailleurs parlé d'un budget de 10
milliards qui seraient étalés sur
plusieurs années à partir de 2021 pour
la revalorisation de ces pensions ça
c'est pas suffisant
en fait si on pouvait être comment dire
qu'on pouvait croire le premier ministre
et le mythe du classement national sur
parole déjà on pourrait commencer à
réfléchir et se demander s'il est
suffisant qu'il soit intéressant nous en
fait on trouve qu'il ya aucune raison
pour que ont subi une perte de nos
pensions on est déjà extrêmement chargé
de travail
les réformes successives qui
s'enchaînent qu'on est vraiment évaluer
en opposition travail de plus en plus
difficile on l'a plus en plus d'élèves
donc on voit pas très bien pourquoi on
devrait en fait avoir des retraites plus
faibles et en plus pour essayer de
compenser un petit peu cet effet
l'astronaute annonce c'est surtout des
primes si j'ai bien compris
alors je me trompe peut-être parce que
l'oci bancaires sont des valorisations
salariale mais également de deux primes
c'est effectivement une forme que quand
il a été interviewé je crois notamment
sur france inter milan et qu'il fallait
repris me l'a dit un peu des deux là
dessus il est resté très flou et je vous
avoue que ban ou le foot ça nous donne
pas du tout confiance et là je pense
qu'on n'a aucune raison de considérer
que c'est suffisamment satisfaisant qui
semble se dessiner c'est plutôt alors ça
te le dise ou des beaux mots à repenser
le métier de professeur au 21ème siècle
mais en fait nous serons voit ce que ça
va impliquer c'est plus de travail moins
de salaire et des conditions détériorées
pour nous et pour les élèves
donc on peut pas trop accepté chat voilà
merci mario chaume d'abord partagé ses
inquiétudes sur tv 78,2 rappelle que
vous êtes professeur de philosophie dans
les yvelines merci d'avoir été avec nous
par téléphone avec la journée de
mobilisation qui a engendré également
des perturbations dans les
établissements scolaires ils innovent
vous l'avez entendu également dans
certains monuments habituellement
ouverts le mardi le château de
versailles est restée fermée aujourd'hui
alors vous le voyez un des personnes ont
pu accéder tout de même aussi puisque
les jardins et est accessible mais pas à
l'intérieur des bâtiments
et comme chaque jour c'est un trafic
habituel si le trafic habituel des
transports qui se retrouvent modifiant
cette période de contestation sociale
vos prévisions de circulation pour la
journée de demain la ligne u sera de
nouveau en circulation partiel un train
toutes les une à deux heures entre les
gares de la défense et de la verrière
est sur un créneau horaire bien
déterminé pour la ligne e n 1 train
toutes les 30 minutes à une heure entre
rambouillet paris montparnasse aux
heures de pointe amplitude horaire
légèrement augmenté tout comme sur l'axé
plaisir grignon pour les lignes de rer
pas de changement un train sur deux en
heure de pointe sur le rer a c'est un
train sur trois sur le rer b aucun train
ne circulera encore sur le rer c entre
paris austerlitz et les gares et de
saint quentin en yvelines versailles
rive gauche et versailles chantiers côté
tramway c'est mieux demain à compter à 4
tram sur cinq sur le trafic du t6 qui
passe par vélizy et viroflay enfin sur
le réseau des skis bus qui dessert
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise un
retour à la normale est prévu pour la
journée de demain voilà ce qu'on pouvait
vous dire sur cette journée de grève
contre la réforme des retraites et sur
ses conséquences dans les yvelines
[Musique]
un mode et municipales au programme pour
rappel les dimanches 15 et 22 mars
prochain samedi une nouvelle liste se
lançait dans la course au scrutin à
villepreux menée par valérie ben agir
avec vous pour villepreux se veut
citoyenne ouverte plurielle et
participative les détails de marylène
iapichino un atelier tri des déchets
pour introduire cette rencontre
participative avec la liste citoyenne
sans étiquette agir avec vous pour
villepreux la liste elle s'est d'abord
près au sujet de ce projet de central
park
et puis du coup au fur et à mesure des
réunions on a parlé avec les uns avec
les autres
on s'est aperçu qu'il y avait aussi
d'autres domaines en fait dans la
gouvernance de la ville sur lesquels ont
souhaité intervenir transition
écologique gel des projets
d'urbanisation et notamment le central
park redonner vie au théâtre municipal
sont les grandes lignes du programme on
veut faire une charte du fonctionnement
du team principal sur justement la
transparence des processus de décision
définir des indicateurs rendre compte en
fait aux villes produisent régulièrement
la liste ambitionne également de
s'investir auprès de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
on est entre guillemets les derniers
entrants donc c'est aussi à nous à
trouver notre place au sein de cette
communauté d'agglo et de faire évoluer
la gouvernance pour que les nouvelles
communes qui viennent de rentrer en fait
dans la communauté d'agglo se sentent
intégrés et que nous à la verse en tant
qu'élu municipal on puisse faire le
relais de la sky auprès des huiles
provient prochaines rencontres
participative le 25 janvier pour agir
avec le point villepreux trois autres
listes sont déjà déclarés sur cette
commune celle du maire sortant stéphane
mirambeau de son ex adjointe sylvie
souvent ont-elles et une dernière menée
par jean baptiste à munich
toute l'actualité des élections
municipales de 2001 retrouvait dans
l'émission 7 8 politique présentée ce
soir par wilfrid richy sur tv 78 et dans
le reste de l'actualité cette conférence
organisée hier sur le site d'atos aux
clayes-sous-bois elle mettait en avant
l' informatique du futur avec
l'ordinateur quantique
partageant et les avancées
technologiques sur le sujet le reportage
de nicolas dandois il contribue au
développement de l'informatique du futur
ingénieur industriel chercheurs ont
participé à cette matinée des changes
organisé par le pôle d'innovation
systématique parmi eux georges raymond
see you de la start-up pascal son
activité le développement d'un
processeur informatique quantique cd des
processeurs de nouvelle génération qui
vont permettre de surmonter les limites
de nos processeurs actuels les dd banque
lance des faux font des calculs toute la
nuit pour optimiser leurs plats lors
leur placement en fait un pur pour gérer
le risque et donc c'est des calculs qui
prennent du temps qu'ils prennent toutes
les nuits l'ordinateur quantique la
possibilité d'accélérer les calculs
informatiques dans tous les domaines
notamment la cybersécurité on sait
détecter de façon certaine s'il ya une
intrusion dans les communications par
exemple et donc de certifier l'intégrité
de ce qu'on reçoit notamment les clés
qui se permettent de chiffrer les
informations de protéger ces
informations cette technologie de
rupture pose des questions sur la
sécurité informatique pour parer à ces
dangers
la start-up crypto next est développe
des solutions donc le problème c'est
qu'il ya certains problèmes dont on n'a
pas envie qu'il soit résolu plus
rapidement et en particulier ceux qui
sont qui permettent de garantir la
sécurité de toutes les communications
nous ce qu'on propose c'est une nouvelle
génération de systèmes de sécurité de
cryptographie qui sont résistants à
l'ordinateur quantique a qui vont
permettre en fait de se préserver de
cette menace
le cantique un secteur en développement
au sein de l'université paris saclay un
centre des sciences et technologies
quantiques baptisé quantum a été lancée
cette année pour rassembler les acteurs
de la recherche dans ce domaine
direction du en cours avec ce projet
d'envergure la construction du futur
siège de gêne harris le groupe
spécialisé dans le conseil en innovation
et le développement disposera en février
2020 du beloit de ce nouveau site va
permettre d'accélérer le développement
du cluster composé de plusieurs start up
nicolas d'andré à nouveau un étage et
demi d'activité
et un étage de fab lab un étage au
bureau aujourd'hui ils sont installés à
magny les hameaux demain les 250
collaborateurs de gennari ce groupe
occuperont ce bâtiment à guyancourt
bubble one le futur siège multi usages
de ce cluster lancé en janvier 2019 le
chantier devrait se conclure en février
2020 on a souhaité donc être
propriétaire d'un immeuble pour être
donc à notre disposition de nos
activités et du projet de cluster de
pouvoir héberger des porteurs de projets
des des start up et puis bien évidemment
prendre en compte aussi l'évolution du
groupe qui est en croissance permanente
une croissance de près de 30% ce cluster
est composé de plusieurs start up
pluridisciplinaire engagés dans
l'innovation différentes infrastructures
sont prévues ce hall occupera une
plateforme d'intégration de systèmes sur
plusieurs types de véhicules des outils
conçus au premier étage on arrive dans
la zone bureau d'études pour concevoir
les produits qui sont fabriqués à
l'étagé en dessous au centre donc il est
prévu que l'on installe des zones de
travail collaboratives
nous avons donc essayé de placer un
certain nombre de salles de réunion et
on va jusque à la faune box qui permet
de faire une colle conférence soit 2
soit tout seul ou bien même prendre une
communication privée le caser cherves
des espaces flexibles multi-usages de
coworking de co-création d'open
innovation nous arrivons à la partie
belle farm donc la partie open
génération c'est une structure capable
de recevoir à la fois des clients qui
nous expriment des besoins recevoir des
porteurs de projets recevoir des start
up qui nous présentent leur technologie
enfin le toit du bâtiment va servir de
terrasse il est prévu aussi des
installations pour la consommation
énergétique du bâtiment s'est installé
un système solaire sur la toiture c'est
récupérer cette énergie solaire dans un
stockeur et se stocker restituera cette
énergie sur des bornes de voitures
électriques et dans l'infrastructure du
bâtiment près de six millions d'euros
ont été investis dans ce projet humble
tout est un peu
ce flux pourrait voir le jour dans les
prochaines années depuis deux ans deux
hommes
ali leur savoir-faire et propose les qui
coaching d'une méthode de coaching avec
un cheval ils travaillent ensemble
essentiellement sur avec pardon avec des
entreprises qui veulent soudé leur
équipe marylène iapichino s'est essayé à
cette technique avec une problématique
gagner en confiance en soi les images de
patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
pour christophe alors je vais l'histoire
liquidation et théologique c'est quoi
les qui coaching alors l'équipe coaching
c'est la mise aux situations d'un d'un
être humain avec un cheval les chevaux
sont dotés d'une hypersensibilité et
sont extrêmement doués pour déceler nos
propres émotions notre propre
intériorité et pour ainsi dire c'est une
forme de rendez vous avec vous mais je
suis invité à faire le tour des box et
choisir le cheval avec lequel je sens
que le fameux secret et ensuite je vous
inviterai à rentrer dans le box ça ça va
être un petit peu difficile
et si c'est un peu difficile n'hésitez
pas à vous me demandez moi je peux vous
accompagnez d'accord
[Musique]
nous partons ensuite sur une autre série
d'exercices aux manèges ont travaillé
quelque chose de plus intérieure vous
allez vous mettre à bonne distance de
jean et vous allez vous rapprocher
d'elle un travaillant le un des
mouvements du bébé qui est le aller vers
et je suis là juste pour vous guider un
tout petit peu et vous avancez
on en essayant de prendre conscience de
ce qu'est ce que ça vous fait de vous
rapprocher du cheval d'aller vers lui
sans sa présence
[Musique]
reda maintenant on va passer sur un
autre petit atelier et je vais vous
demander simplement de prendre un temps
pour vous et pour elle vous allez
essayer de créer du lien avec ces objets
je dois essayer de capter l'attention de
la jument pour la mettre en mouvement
mais ici aussi ce n'est pas très
concluant
[Musique]
en fait j'ai pas du tout envie de
l'interroger moi vous avez pas envie de
la mairie je pense que c'est pour ça
qu'il faisait rien tu as là et pourquoi
vous n'avez pas envie de diriger
bah je sais pas david a laissé
tranquille d'accord c'est après avoir
exprimé mon ressenti que la jument s'est
mise à me suivre le lien est écrit ça on
peut rebondir là dessus même si vous
l'aviez en bts quelle qu elle vous
accompagne lorsque vous reculez d'accord
marylène est ce que cette expérience où
vous a plu vous qui n'avez pas
l'habitude des chevaux mais c'est
intéressant mais là j'ai pu j'ai plus
peur avec elle bilan de cette séance
je n'ai plus peur des chevaux et je sais
qu'une direction n'est pas forcément une
contrainte en séjour côté morrow morrow
ce côté météo un peu de soleil et de
chaleur musicale x1 se déroulent les 19
20 et 21 décembre à saint rémy les
chevreuse et le festival et des musiques
du monde au programme à l'espace jean
racine ont pas on en parle avec moi la
moelle ou bonsoir ça vous êtes le
directeur de la programmation du
festival trois jours de musique trois
jours de musique ont ce pays
représentait trois continents pourquoi
proposer ce festival
quels sont les objectifs nous nous
sommes dit en tant que habitants de la
ville et saint rémy les chevreuse et
puis la suppression des lycéens de
minutieuses qu'il est important pendant
la période hivernale donc au mois de
décembre en particulier où parfois les
gens se réunissent en famille où les
gens au five jeunes dans la région qui
serait possible de mettre en place une
activité un festival de musique comme ça
pour réunion le monde en fait faire des
trois jours d'essai trois jours une
rencontre mondiale entre les habitants
c'est un mois et les artistes qui
viennent de partout un peu et question
de les donner de la joie à toutes les
personnes qui sont dans cette dans cette
ville et dans ces départements des
yvelines alors on écoute tout de suite
un medley des différents artistes qui
seront programmés pour cette première
édition
[Musique]
on dort
ok
[Musique]
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc des artistes qui vient du gabon du
sénégal du brésil d'autres pays comment
vous avez construit cette cette
programmation
il était question pour nos dents dans
ces festivals dans cette première
édition du festival de regarder le monde
dans sa globalité mais à la fois des
d'aller vers ces gens ou des vers ces
pays parfois qui sont proches de la
france mais qui deviennent de plus en
plus très très loin de la france par
rapport à toute la question des
migrations et que vous avez et du
conseiller allons chercher c'est de ces
groupes et ces groupes qui ont quand
même une histoire à travers leur pays
avec la france pour remettre encore les
gens dans une forme de rencontres de
vivre ensemble d'envoi par rapport à
tout ce qui se passe dans le monde
actuellement et on a fait le parcours
des différents pays à travers des
festivals outils de musique pour repérer
certains d'entre eux et puis c'est de la
france ici comme shaman culture qui en
groupes connus il ya longtemps dans ses
dents dans les départements et donc la
plupart on a choisi ces groupes en
disant que c'est ça va faire la faire
pendant le festival couach avait une
culture qui sera à l'affiché le dernier
soir c'est à dire samedi à 20 heures à
l'espace jean racine qu'est ce qu'il
faut retenir de la programmation alors
il ya plusieurs plusieurs têtes
d'affiché deux affiches en général en
soirée et trois affiches le samedi
qu'est-ce qu'il faut affiner samedi
pascal et samedi en fait c'est une
journée assez particulière parce qu'elle
est samedi on commence par avec par la
chanteuse brésilienne angolaise
française le ciel et carvalho qui en
elle toute seule présente un peu
l'humanité donc du coup on s'est dit
qu'on commençait par elle pour un peu
donné l'idée globale et nous avons voulu
dire tout au long de ces festivals et
puis à patrick ruffino qui a un béninois
mais français qui est assez double
identité
la dernière soirée il est vraiment basée
sur la question de la double identité
décès que nous avons en nous tous et
l'idée de faire revenir les gens dès
leur dire voilà nous ne sommes pas que
des là où d'ici nous sommes avant tout
des humains qui se réunissent pour faire
une fête ensemble quoi les chamans
culture pour nous c'est celle à celle à
l'identité dé cette musique ou
l'identité globa des lettres et mais
d'être à la fois c'est qu'il est sait
qui ne l'est pas et c'est qu'on veut
qu'il soit c'est ça qu'on a volé deux
avec simone couture à la fin du
freestyle donc on retrouve bien sûr
toute la programmation sur le site
internet du festival deux jours de
l'ouverture est ce que tout est prêt on
va dire qui et tout était presque prêt
mais il ya y ait des êtres humains qui
réclame des droits qui est qui qui
protestent qui manifestent et qui ont du
droit des faire c'est qui défend et du
coup ça perturbe ap certaines choses du
comes et il ya encore de la place pour
les jeunes qui veulent pas parce qu'on
s'est dit après avoir rêvé après avoir
manifesté après avoir réclamer nos
droits on peut venir aussi fêté danser
chanter et être ensemble vous dire s'il
reste encore des places encore
suffisamment de place pour les trois
jours les gens les festivals et vars et
familiale les enfants les adultes tout
le monde est le bienvenu dans ces
festivals le prix ça va de 15 à 20 euros
il ya même un pass pour les trois jours
quitte à 35 euros précédemment elle a
voulu pour la première édition de ce
festival pour que ce soit accessible à
tout le monde des maîtres un prix assez
raisonnable pour tout le monde donc les
pass 3 jours il n'est pas ce n'est moins
cher de tous les fils de la france 35
euros festival 6-1 jeudi vendredi et
samedi prochains à l'espace jean racine
de saint rémy les chevreuse et plus
d'infos sur notamment les la billetterie
sur le site internet du festival
merci à vous merci moins d'un mois
loudes est revenu sur ce plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes le directeur de
la programmation de ce festival les x1
pour refermer ce journal aurélie ronces
bonsoir de la rédaction tv 78 dans
quelques instants on vous retrouve dans
le 7-8 culture quel est le programme
aujourd'hui on va parler des temps forts
grégory qui nous attendent en fait en
2020 on va aller pour cela au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines puisqu'une
quarantaine de dates sont programmées
l'année prochaine le directeur lionel
masse et à nous en dira plus bien sûr il
y aura du théâtre de la danse de la
musique ou encore la reconstitution d'un
procès historique
elle a été distinguée quatre fois en
2019 lors de la cérémonie des molières
la pièce l'âme
chine de turing sera joué plusieurs fois
en 2020 dans les yvelines
la directrice du tech à plaisir florence
k - vous dira pourquoi il faut
absolument voir ce spectacle
et puis non nous parlerons bien sûr
musique avec la batterie de guyancourt l
établissement annoncera sa programmation
du premier trimestre 2001 alors ce sera
le 16 janvier prochain
mais je peux déjà vous dire qu'il y aura
de la country du reggae du métal
présentation en avant-première dans le
circuit de culture donc de ce soir et
c'est dans quelques minutes sur tv 78
merci aurélie voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci d'avoir suivi le replay
sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]